[Música]
i
se preguntarán por qué tengo una pelota
no ella fue uno de los pilares
fundamentales a lo largo de toda mi vida
en síntesis le dio sentido a mi vida
está en especialmente la guardo con
mucho amor tiene un par de pinchazos
pero me la regaló mi mamá cuando tenía
nueve años en un cumpleaños
como no tenía el dinero para poder
comprar la otra después que se pinchaba
me salía un peso con 50 centavos y
apartarla y la tenía con mucho amor
cuando cuando era chico
me encantaba me encantaba jugar al
fútbol me aboqué a eso empecé a jugar
desde los 6 años en la escuelita de
fútbol donde me mandó mi mamá
me encantó tanto que me aboqué
totalmente a esto porque era lo que me
encantaba y me daba la posibilidad
pero
me pasaba algo con la escuela
no me gustaba para nada totalmente para
nada ir a la escuela
sufría
ayer me mis inicios en cruzar el orden
las inferiores
no me gustaba para nada ir a la escuela
porque
sufría bullying porque tenía
lastimosamente el al único chico de la
primaria que usaba brackets en ese
momento y era todo momento un tipo de
abuso que ellos sufrían en la escuela y
sentía que a los docentes tampoco le
interesaba lo que a mí me pasaba
esto lo sufrí por mucho tiempo y para mí
era una tortura total ir a la escuela
esos sentimientos que yo a mí se me
generaba en la cancha no lo encontraba
en ningún otro lado con mi familia capaz
un poco ausente por temas laborales mi
mamá se separó de mi papá de chico y
éramos siete hermanos más uno más
la familia bastante numerosa gracias a
dios
y lastimosamente aunque seamos la
familia numerosa yo sentía una ausencia
muy grande que tampoco la podía llenar
en la escuela entonces todo lo que a mí
se me generaban las cosas más lindas me
pasan en una cancha con una pelota de
fútbol
ahí aprendí millones de cosas que hasta
hoy en día la sigo desarrollando que
aprendí para toda la vida
y así fueron pasando desde chiquitos fui
creciendo me fui desarrollando en el en
el fútbol fui agarrando maurel se
jueguen las inferiores crucero del norte
jugué en la selección misionera de
fútbol sub-15 tuve la posibilidad de
jugar al estudiante de la plata en
buenos aires y demás
hasta que volví
y por un problema de salud que tuve del
corazón tuve que dejar tuve que dejar
todo tipo de actividad que realizaba y
creo que era como que el mundo se me
cayó era el el mundo que ellos formen
desde chico se me caía a pedazos que
tanto esfuerzo me costó que me aboqué a
eso que era lo que más ama
y por una fuerza mayor lo perdí todo
entonces como no voy a realizar ninguna
actividad empecé a buscarme a la escuela
lastimosamente
que tendría que seguir siendo tuve que
empezar a buscarme la escuela de vuelta
yo tenía un sueño
como millones de personas en el mundo
siguen frustradas como yo me frustré
eras el jugador profesional y tenía la
esperanza de llegar a este tercer año de
secundaria y abandonar y a buscarme
especialmente lo que me gustaba
pero por esta razón no no no no puede
seguir
además tenía que ir a la escuela
obligadamente totalmente porque si no
iba a la escuela mi mamá no me podía el
ine no iba a dar el dinero para asistir
a entrenar entonces era ir a la escuela
y aprobar todas las materias total
entonces paso me paso el problema de
salud hace un tiempito atrás
dado que a la escuela
empecé a ver que había algunas fallas
con mis compañeros que había cosas que
yo podía cambiar
había momentos que podía crear que ellos
necesitaban cosas pero no sabían cómo
pedirlos ni dónde pedir las entonces
intenté cambiar muchas cosas en ellos en
mi cambiaron mucho vinieron otros
sentimientos empecé a encontrar cosas en
la escuela que pensé que nunca iba a
poder a encontrar hasta cambió mi manera
de pensar sobre los docentes que tenía
un dolor muy grande por dentro por la
atención que yo no sentía de ellos y
cambió totalmente porque un docente fue
el que me impulsó a seguir en este sueño
me impulsó a seguir aquí había cosas que
yo podía cambiar que podía cambiar en la
escuela
me hice partícipe del centro de
estudiantes de la institución ni la
mínima idea de qué se trataba
nunca la vida me enteré de eso y me hice
participe y empezar esta carmen en
diferentes roles de la escuela empecé a
formar más actividades a participar en
eventos y fui logrando cosas junto a
todos mis compañeros
llegó un momento en que aunque haga
todas esas cosas yo sentía una
desmotivación de los estudiantes de los
adolescentes de por qué no terminan la
secundaria o porque hay un no hay un
objetivo creado entonces
cree junto con mis docentes referentes
un proyecto que se llama busquemos un
motivo una razón para seguir
tiene la base fundamental de la
educación emocional que se gracias a
dios se pudo aprobar la ley ahora
provincial
este proyecto que yo armé se trata se
basa fundamentalmente en
que los adolescentes de los jóvenes
tengamos objetivos creados que busquemos
lugares que tengamos docentes con
personas en quien apoyarnos en todo
momento en
poder estos lugares crearlos junto a los
docentes de terminar la secundaria de
seguir un camino hacia la educación
terciaria o universitaria
a buscarme especialmente a esto y me
encantó me encantó totalmente soy
referente de educación emocional lo
trato con mis profesoras todo el tiempo
con la psicóloga
armo de diferentes actividades para
proveer proyectar esto que esta idea que
yo tengo
creo que los jóvenes sufren esta
desmotivación que hay porque no se
plantean objetivos así como yo tenía
objetivo en la secundaria tenía otros
objetivos
pero era plantearme una cosa o nada más
y así no es para mí ahora que cambie de
pensamiento es
diferentes objetivos durante toda la
vida y abocarse totalmente a eso y que
dar todo de sí dar todo de sí porque
aunque fallamos una o dos veces hay que
seguir intentando porque se logra se
terminan logrando muchísimas cosas y
todos los cambios que se producen y los
cambios que se produjeron en mí quiero
que se produzcan en otros jóvenes así
como estamos está lleno el salón de
jóvenes hoy quiero que se produzca lo
mismo que pasó en mí en todos
entonces
cambiar cosas plantean objetivos crear
buenas relaciones humanas
como lo decía eduardo galiano somos lo
que hacemos para cambiar lo que somos
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]